today I'm game life we're talking of
legendary indie game designer Jonathan
Blow Jerry bean I don't know why I said
that welcome to the game life video
podcast we have an extra special guest
for you guys today it's very true it as
a creator a beloved indie game braid and
also creator of forthcoming puzzle
adventure game the witness Jonathan Blow
is here with us thanks for having me on
so we we still know so little about the
witness what we do know it's
first-person very atmospheric puzzle
game but I'm curious where the real
birth of this game was its inspired by
mists and the whole lineage of games
that mist kind of kicked off and so the
idea was to take the the best parts of a
game like mist so the atmosphere and the
mood and just that setting of you're in
a place and you have all the time that
you need to figure things out and to
bring a modern game design sensibility
to it and what it ends up being is not
so much an adventure game but like a
hybrid first-person exploration with
like puzzles like more abstract puzzles
mm-hmm there really is pretty close to
no action in the witness and it's not
because I think actions bad it's just
that so many games do it like there's
sort of two different things that happen
when a game wants to provide difficulty
and one way harkens back to arcades
where it was all action II right space
invaders or pac-man or whatever is all
about moving fast and the other way is
you know then RPGs came around it was
about making appropriate tactical
decisions right and those are sort of
the two ways that we know in videogames
of how to be challenging and it doesn't
seem like very much it doesn't seem like
a very broad palette so while you might
expand in the future for now the ps4 is
the is the home console that yes DC and
iOS as we've talked about what was
behind that you know why Sony rat you
know brain started with Microsoft's a
lot of so for a while you know the
development cycle of the witness has
stretched onward when I originally
announced the game I said it was gonna
be winter 2011 or something and it
hasn't made that release date but that's
meant for good reasons right it's
because we've seen an opportunity to
make a game that speaker and scope where
the world is richer that looks nicer and
so we're taking that opportunity right
but
part of what that means is that earlier
business plans get invalidated right so
we originally thought okay we're gonna
try and do PC and ps3 or xbox which
would have made a lot of sense in 2011
right but then we just took long enough
developing the games and it's like hey a
new console time yeah and it made it
easier so then it came down to well
there's these two consoles I kind of
know more about one because I'd been
working with Casoni has been very
proactive about working with Indies
right and that can't be overstated I
mean last year you know unfinished Juan
in Papua yo and and journey and they
really have have changed their stance on
unnourished so look back back last year
they invited a bunch of Indies out and
there were you know 50 of us in a room
getting this serious tech briefing and
like I don't think either Nintendo or
Microsoft would have done that no guys
yeah I wouldn't expect and then to have
done that's how we get like during
during that meeting I said okay this is
interesting I want a dev kit now yeah
and then they they got me one very young
after that yeah and then there you go
was just thinking that outreach getting
you interested you know that totally
yeah thanks Jonathan Jonathan Blow has
been here with us
be sure to check out our other videos
with Jonathan and Veronica Belmont who's
going to be joining us as we sit down to
talk about what always-on really means
the future generation of consoles and
what the challenges of developing for
those consoles are
gillich game my video subscribe to wires
YouTube channel right now please come on
like the bud